welcome to this video playing I don't
know dekha their shop maybe someone
someone help me ok we have a dragon and
as I don't know the really sharp lines
player more strategically in client
setup it's not it's not bad some been
played by by carp off a couple of times
in the 70s and 80s and this should be
some some stamp of approval he really
had his opening sir nicely set up okay
let's see might a five year okay night
c4 is certainly possible but I don't
mind to to trade this and play Bishop
age 6 I don't I cannot expect really
much from the set up anyway but what
right sometimes manages to do is to put
a piece on d5 knight on d5 of course not
the piece that's always a night and
provoke black to to capture it so that
you have play on the half-open e-file so
let's let's see of course i'd like to
get rid of this this this fianchetto
bishops are bishop age success a move
that i really like to make
okay typically dynamic play of a dragon
the dragon player and okay before yeah c
2 is of course a bit weak so i need to
watch out for that still be our store
maybe first a 3m i don't i don't really
know if you can go before ok does not
yeah takes takes 194 night is 6mm that's
not that's not really great and he can
take a form
hmm yeah it's not not so comfortable
yeah I don't really see a good defense
iam sorry I wanted to go here this is a
bit passive but I don't really see a
good move
hmm ok so probably I made some kind of
mistake it's not like I'm expecting to
have a great tech yeah but I shouldn't
be in trouble with good play but now I'm
and I'm a bit under pressure here made
it in fact if he just retreats now the
questions where we can even go to c5
with possible rook age five moves yeah
and that's not not comfortable yeah
default
before I'm going to take and play 91 now
this looks really awful I didn't see a
van active muth an active continuation I
was trying various things in my mind how
to maybe sacrifice the sea to pawn but I
never I didn't really see a way to make
it work yeah yeah yeah simple simple
chest but good maybe if I of young takes
this could be an IBM this is an idea de
94 Knight takes Knight technics I'm
threatening the rook and 95 and if we
move the rock I can take be five which
is at least I'm messy ok you would have
taken on e5 with the rook I would have
exchanged and taken on pull on b5 maybe
this is wasn't impossible maybe you
should have taken with the rookie I'm ok
I don't know what's going on here though
that's a it's a it's complicated nights
if Roxy for maybe if I take let's say
queen bee 7 and I have some lights
hanging and I don't have a good square
to go mmm proxy 40 is just sacrificing
the exchange ok
not sure that it was it wasn't necessary
to do that not saying that it is
necessarily bad but it was not necessary
okay peace may be intending to take on
after know if I move the night he takes
on f2 we are with Nyjah for coming this
is my night 5 is probably not great oh
wait I can still do that it's still it's
still interesting okay
at the end I've got back to the team on
only seven or could have taken only six
after an earlier context of two so good
yeah yeah let's see okay see pawn
certainly the the pawn that should
should win me the game while this was
probably very stupid square to go to Wow
93 and don't believe it Wow very stupid
I've spoiled most of most of my
advantage early check I'm winning on
time yeah check black portage on time
very very stupid rookie five how stupid
was that move I mean I can just go
anywhere here a seven or something from
the 87 just out of harm's way and it's
just in exchange for nothing you guys
got some activity with the two pieces
but why should certainly win that um he
didn't need to sacrifice the exchange I
think here black is completely fine of
course yeah this is the problem I my
idea was to do that but then as I
mentioned there's Queen d7 with a double
attack and this means that my idea is
not really working and here i would have
need to play something like that and
that's just that's just better for black
much much better yeah really was
outplayed him thus I wasn't was nice at
all b5 was a very strong move
that really are that really sets it some
problems can I was wondering about this
but he can just take it and yeah maybe I
can do that maybe I can do that here I
was afraid of rook takes but I have
Quincy one of course you can take here
though yeah something like that i can i
can play but it's not good of course
it's um basically a pawn down I mean
this is just useless and black has a
perfectly sound structure yeah I made
some some mistake in the opening I
shouldn't really be be worse on term may
be 94 here on i-5 and I I must play if
I've this is a typical a typical move ah
yeah okay yeah this is this is the what
this is the reason why Knight a5 is not
good okay this is the thing is you
cannot take out this is very easy gives
away a piece so he must take here and
after the recapture something like that
come on can take here and this is maybe
mmm is this is something yeah black
stills has has a pretty decent position
of course and it's also no refutation
really yeah I don't know it was some
good lucky this winner thanks for
watching